what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of unwaxed with your
favorite sisters sophia
and sistine stallone this time i didn't
sing the stallone part
hi guys welcome back um happy tuesday
thanks for listening again before we
jump into the episode i would just love
to recap
the listeners subscribe subscribe on
apple podcast
on spotify to our youtube channel
make sure you leave your unsolicited
advice in our ratings and review section
am i forgetting anything
no we have our gmail you know if you
have your bedtime stories so
send them in any inquiries if you want
to sponsor us that would be awesome you
know
we're not trying to tug your arm but if
you would like to sponsor us
that would be so cool that would be
really cool who would you want to
sponsor us
wait no we can't put the plug in because
they're not sponsoring us maybe like a
nice little liquor company or maybe like
a nice lingerie
look i feel like that's something we're
so bad at i listen to a lot of podcasts
and everyone
is constantly plugging themselves and we
don't i know
we just need to start doing it more and
we do i feel like everyone's like oh
have you monetized your instagram and we
used to
and i go what does that mean how do we
do it because we're running this
ourselves but i i think it's actually
kind of nice because we've really just
honed in on
making sure this podcast works yes it is
a well-oiled machine and so far it is uh
it is on half tank right now we're
running low fuel but we're getting
through it and
just a reminder we really do listen
listen
we really do read all of your comments i
mean i was on it this morning
reading the comments that you guys left
for us and let me just say
the love is mutual i wish i could i wish
i could see your face
that would be fun let me know talk to
them one on one maybe we'll have a
listener on one day
you know someone suggested that we do a
live
podcast would you guys be interested in
that they're like
no please don't i want to say i'm a
little nervous because what if we say
he's stupid which most likely most
likely but yeah let us know if you guys
want to hear our podcast live that'd be
really fun
i have a super secret surprise what is
it sistine
i have a guest caller on the show right
now she's actually been
on my computer this whole time making
stupid faces at me
um but here she is would you like to say
hello
hello everyone it's me the third sister
and your favorite it's scarlett it's
scarlet
scarlett is currently why don't you
describe what she's doing sophia
scarlett is on facetime smashing her
beauty blender into her cheekbone to
create
a fake jawline so scarlett all right
don't expose me like this
so scarlett i called you back because
i would love to give the listeners a
little update on you
we are very excited because yesterday
we found scarlett her prom dress
yes not only we found my prom dress but
we found it
online oh well
where else would we find it it's a
pandemic so
it's risky yes um we got options
we'll see what happens yeah but i would
just love to talk about prom scarlett
who are you going with
you guys i don't have a date what do i
do loser
i would like to know where you learn to
be
so uncool because that is not yeah
that's just not
alone both sister christine from my two
older sisters
no no no cece and i both had boyfriends
and dates
so who are you really going with
i i got asked but i think i'm just gonna
go with the girlfriend does that sound
really lame
no i don't think it's lame
i think it's sweet um no i think going
with girls is fun i think
you know her at this point i think i'm
just gonna take my dog
just take the dog so bringing up prom um
brings up a lot of memories because uh
you looked hot in your prom dress
hot well we have very different prom
stories
yes should i go first mine's easy i'll
just shoot
first so it's prom
it is 2016 15
15 i think i graduated and i am
ready this i'm the first daughter out of
the family to go
and it is a big deal for girls to find
their prom dress and
every girl in the class is like sharing
photos saying you can't buy this you
can't copy me
and so i don't know why but this year
i was set on getting a white dress
all i wanted all i want is my prom dress
to be a white dress i wanted to walk in
like hillary duff in a cinderella story
i wanted to be cinderella
there's nothing wrong with a white dress
it is just a very hard find it's a hard
hard i almost i basically asked my mom
to do the impossible with me
yeah and when i say it was impossible i
mean it was impossible because
because we hit i kid you not maybe
10 different stores big department
stores
small stores online nothing the guy just
has to put on a suit
i know but my mom i my mom's like are
you sure sophia there's so many other
colors
there's every other color and you were
just so sad i was like no mom
i need it to be white so
my mom says you know why don't we try
anthropology because you know the
upstairs
has some gowns and i go oh okay mom
what kind of gown what kind of gowns she
doesn't we'll just just i'll show you
we go up it's a wedding dress shop
yeah no a legitimate wedding dress shop
so so instead of me going
this is a little funky me trying on
wedding dresses in front of my mom
before anything i did it so i found this
dress
right my mom says this is the perfect
one
it looked full bridal
you guys full bride to be walking down
the aisle it was
strapless lace from top to bottom
it had a satin cotton bow it was
wedding dress it wasn't like i i thought
it had a train
you you're probably thinking it could be
a bridesmaid dress like maybe flowy
enough
no no no wedding wedding so
my mom was out of town so she couldn't
be with me when the guy came to pick me
up
or the whatever so i stepped in it's the
same subject my dad was late so he
wasn't there
but you know who did pull up was my
date's mom
and the face she made when she saw me
in a wedding dress with her son and
she was a suit just about ready to turn
that prius around and go back down the
drawer
honestly it was the most uncomfortable
thing it was just the three of us
and you in the background well
especially because
mothers have a weird relationship with
sometimes their oldest son or their
firstborn do you know what i mean oh
yeah so to see
their day or his date in a bridal gown
very jealous i've never married jealousy
yeah i've never
i've never had problems with moms and
guys like i've always been very very
good when i meet
the guy's mom but sometimes that has the
problem yeah but i was this was the only
guy that i just didn't know her that
well and i
totally understand how it could have
looked and i look back on the photos and
it makes me
laugh so hard should we post them yes i
will post it like
this this is funny if it's right in the
middle my wedding dress
shout
he's a great guy prom prom in a nutshell
isn't that fun unfortunately mine wasn't
just to say you went
yeah i mean i was on a yellow school bus
on my way to prom
it's not like some glamorous i think you
watch movies growing up thinking it's
going to be
like high school musical where they all
break out in choreography and they're
like it's going to be
the night yes oh i thought it was going
to be cinderella story i know and it's
just gonna be romantic but it's really
not you're uncomfortable you're sweating
you're taking photos you're taking
awkward pictures with this guy you're
like oh my god
you know it's just the whole thing is
just weird yeah but what happened with
yours
mine wasn't so bad i was in a very so we
went to a catholic high school a very
strict
conservative catholic high school and i
didn't end up buying a prom dress i just
ended up using
a gown that i'd worn for an event maybe
like a month prior and it was sexy it
was hot
she was hot not school of pro no her
date was like
his eyes were going wow which is good
which is good but the whole day was
pretty hectic because we had
shot a big campaign that entire day
and then right when i got home i had all
of my friends and their dates
already at my house ready to take
pictures so i was like [ __ ]
i don't have any dress like i did not
prepare for this at all
so i just threw on this one and um
i got in trouble for the dress
yes i did and they called my parents
i don't remember that you know what mom
and dad did no
what they no parents were allowed it was
very strange as well you weren't allowed
to pick up your kid at a certain time
you had to stay
in the prom for from like 6 p.m
to 11 or 12 feet like you weren't
allowed to leave weren't allowed to get
picked up
no excuses jennifer and sly pull up and
say
you don't like what she's wearing we'll
take her somewhere else more fun
so she picked up me and my date they
drove like 45 minutes
picked us up and we went and had a great
time the four of us
oh that's awesome yeah that's awesome
yeah it was really sweet it was one of
those moments we were like oh those are
some cool parents
yeah they're cool parents but prompts
suck prom sucked
sucks if you're planning on going to
prom go absolutely go
but it sucks if you guys have good prom
stories that would be nice let me know
i'd love to read them
or some bad ones does anyone have
actually a good prom
period period question mark i'm excited
for scarlet though i don't know why i
think she's so lucky
because she has two sisters yeah that
have been through it
that know exactly the perfect way to
look for her
we're gonna perfect she's our little
doll we're gonna she's our mannequin
we're gonna dress her up we're gonna do
her hair and makeup i'm so excited so
excited
except now that i'm thinking about it
prom in a pandemic
she'll probably have to wear a mask the
whole time will she even need to wear
makeup
oh i hope how are you going to take
pictures
are they going to get tested and stuff
first like that's not going to be fun to
wear a mask the whole time
we should throw her a prom we should
throw our prom
that would be we will
to change directions in this system okay
um i'm sorry i woke you up a couple days
ago
screaming laughing and you thought i was
killing someone when i was talking i
so when i i don't know if you guys know
this but i'm a pretty
loud person and when i say loud i just
mean my voice
is just carries like the way i just talk
right now
in the mic our voices are just so much
louder our dad trained us that way
though
he really was saying enunciate use your
vocals to scream i don't know he just
always made us
yell and talk very loudly so i was
explaining something that happened the
night before to my mom but
because my voice carried throughout the
house it woke everyone up in the house
and this was around 7
30 in the morning maybe earlier
yeah i just thought either she's crying
getting yelled at
or something really funny must have
happened
i'm glad everyone came in because i am i
made everyone
cry laughing and i'm going to tell you
guys what happened
and this you know what genuinely
i don't even know what to say i have no
words yet i have all of the words
you know what i mean it's just one of
those things that only would happen to
sophia
once again once it is a classic sofia
story period so you guys are probably
wondering what we're talking about here
so when this thing happened i knew in
the moment i'm like
my family is going to roast me
so hard okay here it goes we did so do
you guys remember i think
i don't know if it's two episodes ago or
maybe it was last episode
uh sistine brought up that i went on a
date i did not go on a date recently
just giving fyi i'm not like here and
there but this happened on the same date
when i went on the foie gras
when i tasted that food yes okay yes i
didn't i didn't finish
like talking about it um so
i'm just gonna set us back maybe like a
couple hours before the date
my nails right now look like [ __ ] my
sister scarlett said dip was a good idea
dip is not a good idea your nails fall
off when i say your nails i mean like
yes my nails
are super short they look like baby
fingers and
they're just rough and nothing's working
and i'm about to go on the state
and i'm at target with my mom and
sistine and my mom goes
you know some of my girlfriends use
those press-on nails
yeah they work they just stay on they
look real and i got
seven bucks yeah i was like are you sure
mom like i've never done that before and
she goes no no no do it do it do it
and i go okay sure you know what screw
it i'll buy these black ones
black of course like that matte black
matte black matte black nails let me
just scare him like it's halloween and
it's not summer soon
um and so right before i'm like okay i'm
gonna quickly do it so i put on these
nails
all over and they stay they're feeling
good they're
on my nails they look stunning they're
thank you and they did look they looked
real i'm like guys
everyone do this i want god to do this
follow my lead follow my lead get stick
on nails screw paying for
40 dollar manicures that's what you're
doing get sticky nails
so
i go on this date and i'm sitting with
him and i'm talking
she said get sticking nails
what so i'm sitting
and
[Music]
you guys this is so funny because this
is what happened
so i'm very expressive with my hands as
well
sophia you're like
so i'm very expressive with my hands as
well yeah and i'm in the midst
of this very interesting i guess
conversation
and suddenly as i'm talking to him this
is probably an hour in
my mind pinky nail falls up
where does it fall sofia and lance and
and the tartar so her press on fake now
all of a sudden i'm talking and i see my
nail fly into the food
flies into the tartare and i go
wait wait so i go oh my god and i look
up at him i look at the food
i look up he's looking at me like what
and i go oh my god and i start to grab
it all of a sudden
they all start falling off and let me
just say
one at a time they're popping yes wait
wait but can i just explain before this
he saw my nails and he said your nails
look
great they're very intimidating but i'm
like yeah i know i got them done
recently i'm not going to tell them
we're sticking
i'm not telling you if i bought sticky
nails from target so it complements your
nails
so which complimented my nails five
minutes later they're in the food
because
i told him i told him i got them done so
it looks like i'm decaying
it's literally my nails are popping off
into the food
and i'm trying to catch them how many
fell off
like four it's so i literally go
and so i went quickly under the table
like sticky that's ratchet
that's so ratchet oh and i'm like
i go oh i'm sorry i don't know why this
is happening
like can you give me a second so i go to
the bathroom no you don't
i'm ripping them off i'm like i can't
wear them i can't wear them what'd you
say when you came back what did you say
when you came out i was like oh i guess
they just
didn't like guess the fake nails at the
salon didn't work
and i just kept going i was distracting
like so hey howard that how's that
tartar doing
did he still no no no one touched
anything no one ate the tartar
yes because my fake nails were all over
the food
oh god did he ever call you back after
this date
he sent a nice text okay he's a team
player but you are
nasty can you imagine if it was the say
if a guy had
fake eyebrows on and his fake eyebrow
fell into the food
you would say this man's disgusting i'm
out of here i'm never doing sticky nails
again but this is the problem this also
reminds me of a time the first
and this is my this is the issue
everyone out there
don't do something for the first time
with someone you don't know
don't touch because i remember in
college i tried to use fake lashes for
the first time on a date
another one idiot sophia guess what
happened i
i was so proud of myself that i got
these damn things on they're hard if you
know how much time it takes when you're
first getting into it
so i got them on i was really proud of
myself and i'm talking to scott and he
kept looking
up in the middle of my forehead or
somewhere i was like i don't know why he
has a weird eye contact
problems and so i'm like i'm gonna go to
the bathroom so i go to the bathroom
it's towards the end of the day
my lash is hanging off my eye
it looks like i have no lashes so
i don't know why i didn't learn my
lesson but for those out there
don't do sticky nails for the first time
on a date don't do false lashes for the
first time on it but i also feel like
it's an important message
to just laugh at yourself it was fun and
it's all about how you bounce back
and you were able to laugh and he was
able to laugh if you've been
drama then he would have been
uncomfortable too yeah so i think it's
fine psa yeah if funny things happen on
a date that are weird and awkward
just go along with it don't judge it he
was super cool about it and it
now i have a story for you guys
and that was such a good story it could
have been a bedtime story
i know it should have been a bedtime
story but hey we're gonna kick off this
episode with some
heat some hilarious stories and we're
gonna also bring in someone that
is also amazing you guys we have
an incredibly smart wise individual
coming on his name is rob dial
and if you haven't already seen his
content you must look it up because he
is the real deal we talk about
everything from
manifesting what you want to how
starting your day
will change the whole way you live your
life to what else are we talking about
to
being an entrepreneur in 2021 what to do
with that and how to also differentiate
between instant gratification and hard
work how to stop being lazy i mean we
touch all of it and it is such a cool
conversation so
stay tuned for that okay you guys we
have
an incredible guest joining us today he
is a motivational speaker
whose life purpose it is to help release
people from mental
suffering he has traveled all around the
world and connected with over 50 000
individuals through speaking and
coaching while doing all of this
he has his own podcast which just so
happened to hit
number one on itunes in six categories
called the mindset and motivation
podcast
and if that wasn't impressive enough he
has over 1 billion views
on facebook alone we have the fabulous
rob dial ladies and gentlemen
thank you for coming on rob we're really
excited to have you on today for sure
well yeah thank you for having me i uh
you know i i just i wanted to make my
podcast with how my personality is and
i'm i'm short i'm to the point i'm very
no bs
and so for me it was just like i'm just
gonna speak exactly how i am and if it
resonates with people and it does and
i'm i'm a lot of people's cup of tea and
i'm definitely not some people's cup of
tea but you know it
people will find whoever they're whoever
they resonate with and i just happen to
to resonate with a good amount of people
so i'm glad that
i'm glad i resume with you guys oh you
definitely did
so one of the first questions i had in
my mind that i want to ask you was about
this whole trend of wanting to be an
entrepreneur in 2021 and i
think it's just been happening since
2019 that everyone's thinking that this
is probably going to be
the coolest career like very trendy
everyone wants their own business and
just to say the word entrepreneur is
very
i guess um millennials want to be their
own boss but for sure you
were saying i think in one of your
episodes about how
we have this idea of instant
gratification and they don't realize
like you're an entrepreneur and i mean
we're trying to be entrepreneurs
it takes time there's a lot of so what
do you say to someone that
wants to become an entrepreneur um well
so
i don't even the thing about it is like
i think it's become like this hot word
that people
want to be an entrepreneur i think it
makes them feel good about what they say
that they're doing but
um i guess i would be considered an
entrepreneur but i've never actually
like said
i'm an entrepreneur any sort of way um
but what i say is if you want to be an
entrepreneur you're basically waking up
to be punched in the face
every day you know like there's that's
the way that it's true yeah
gary vaynerchuk says something really
great where it's like very few people
should be entrepreneurs
everybody else can be like a number two
or number three in a company there's
nothing wrong with being a number two or
number three
um because there's a lot of people who
are number two and number three and
facebook that are now worth
half a billion dollars because they were
number two and number three in a big
company and they're they're necessary
but um you know i think i think what it
comes down to is
in the thing i love about millennials
and everyone that comes after
millennials is that
you know i'm on like the edge of
millennial in in my age group so i'm
like the
the oldest millennial that you can be i
think uh but for me what i find is that
people
just don't want to work with somebody
and i don't think anybody ever really
wanted to work
for somebody we want freedom more than
anything else you know like people
i always say the main thing people are
always looking for is freedom that's it
so like
when people want to make money they
don't really care about the money what
they want is the freedom that the money
gives them
right and so when you think about work
people want to be free from being told
what to do they want to do something
that they love the thing i love about
you know i'm 35 and so the i've been
through some stuff but the younger
generations
i find are more loving more caring and
they think way outside of the box than i
think the older generations do
and i think that 20 20 shoulders showed
us that
society is changing like and that's not
something wrong it's a beautiful thing
that's starting to change
and i think with millennials with the
opportunities with instagram
i mean there's so many opportunities
that are out there that that
the internet has brought and uh and i
think for a lot of people if it's what
they want to do and they want to get
free of the system i mean you can
you can make 60 000 thousand dollars a
year
decently easily online you just have to
find something that you actually love
and that you're passionate about and
then follow it
but i think that's the key to it is not
going into it for the money like
we we weren't going into podcasting to
make money that wasn't our goal i mean
our goal was to connect with a bunch of
people and i guarantee that's like the
same thing for you like we
when people asked why we were going into
podcasting and like how much we always
wanted to make our friends really we
barely they don't we ask that monetize
we don't do it yet we're like we really
want to first create good content and
put it out there
and the things that have been coming
because we went into that mindset with
the intention
of making this a really great show where
people can feel like we're their sisters
and relate to it and that's
that's how you go into it um but it was
hard in the beginning because
we are slightly kind of in i mean i'm 25
so it's i'm not
i use a dictionary when i was in middle
school so it's like
today you can go on siri and just like
look up something and you get the answer
so i think it i think people forget how
much
work it does take consistently to grow
that podcast and so i for you my
question for you would be
when people want that instant
gratification how do you bring them back
and go okay you actually do need to
probably work
first and know what you like to do and
how do you get that passion
and yeah i've so the thing about it is
like nothing
worth anything ever happens right away
so like nobody is under the impr it's it
kind of boggles mine nobody's under the
impression that they like eat one salad
and they like lose five pounds nobody
would ever think that right like they're
never gonna have the body they want from
one salad
they're not gonna go to the gym one time
and just get some really big muscles
that'd be great it would be great it
would be so much easier right it'd be
great
but but it's not going to happen but it
so it kind of boggles my mind that
people think oh i'm going to start a
business and then in three months i'm
going to be a multi-millionaire
and there's a lot of people that flex on
instagram that are if i'm being honest
they're just completely full of it right
like they absolutely go rent a
lamborghini they rent a ferrari and
they're like oh
follow me and i'll teach you how to do
it right and um
and they don't they don't actually have
those things so people follow on
instagram and they think to my
themselves oh this guy did this in three
months
when in reality they probably didn't but
i've i've been running my business for
three months now and i'm not a
multi-millionaire and it's like for me
you know it took me four years before my
business ever crossed a million dollars
in a year you know and it's like it
takes time
and then what's crazy though is because
i put in it's kind of like the momentum
the way i
describe it is like if i were to take a
15-pound bowling ball
you and i were to go to the top of a
hill and i were to drop it if you were
to stop it right away
it's not hard to stop because it's
there's not momentum on its side
but if you want to stop that bowling
ball at the bottom it's going to break
your hand
because it's got so much momentum
outside and that's what a business does
it piles on top of itself where it's
like
it took four years to get to a million
but then the next year we did five
million
and it's like it literally grows that
fast but people want it to be like the
first six months to see success and does
that happen it does happen
but what i always tell people and the
reason you said you know go for
something you're passionate about like
i love what i do i'm super passionate
about it you know i've coached tens of
thousands of people
and i'm just obsessed with it's what i
love to do and
um so i don't i don't see this as work
like i love doing this gives me more
energy to to literally sit speak to you
guys to talk to all the people who are
going to be listening
it gives me energy so i don't i don't
lose energy from doing this for a year
two years three years five years where i
go okay
what's something i love that i can be
okay with dedicating
i don't even want to say dedicating my
life to because most people don't
need to dedicate their entire lives
that's what most people think is that
i need to find something i'm going to do
for the rest of my life
and when you look at passion what i
think would help a lot of your listeners
is there's two ways there's two
different types of people
one's a jackhammer which is i'm like a
jackhammer like i know what i want i
just go for it i'm hardcore i'm good
with it
but most people there's a jackhammer on
the other side there's a uh
a hummingbird and a hummingbird if
you've ever seen a hummingbird it goes
from one flower
to the next flower to the next flower to
the next flower and some people with
their passions is like
they go to one flower and they can stay
for a few years
dedicate three four five years of their
life and they might go you know what
what's the next thing
and there's nothing wrong with that but
if your listeners are going alright i
want to start a business then ask
yourself what can i put five years into
and then put five years because you're
gonna it's gonna take you three years to
really really see success
and then if at five years you wanna
stick with it stick with it if you don't
want to
you can let it go and move on to the
next thing but it's not gonna happen in
six months to a year
no i think i really wanna touch on the
momentum thing
because i think that even before you get
to finding
your passion or what you want to do i
think a lot of people are even scared to
try
whether it's the fear of failure the
fear of disappointing their family
i mean the fear of disappointing
themself so
i definitely am one to negative
self-talk
like i will cut myself down more than
anyone and i'm lucky because i have
a very supportive family that is my my
cheerleaders and anything i do but i am
my harshest critic
and i'm always just afraid to try
so for people like me that are like okay
i really want to pursue this business
like i really want this to happen
but taking the first step is [ __ ]
terrifying for sure what
what do i how do i even begin yeah so
well first off so one thing i say in the
mindset mentor all the time is
this analogy this beautiful analogy from
the guy named uh
tony robbins favorite book is is a book
that talks about
uh as it's called as a man thinketh and
what he says is imagine your mind as a
garden
right and you're the only one that can
go to this garden right so nobody else
can walk up to your garden
you can't think that you can take
strawberry seeds and put them in the
ground
and that that tomatoes are going to grow
right you you know that's not possible
what's happening though is that people
are walking into their garden and
they're putting in negative thoughts
negative thoughts negative thoughts but
they're expecting their life to just be
positive
it's not going to happen like you have
to literally plant the seeds that you
want
here's the problem though we all have
negative thoughts i have negative
thoughts all day
but i'm like no i'm not gonna [ __ ] do
it to get out of my head like it's
it's immediate like i gotta pull it and
it's like if you're tending a garden
what's gonna happen you're going to get
weeds right so you are the only one that
can pull these weeds so you notice it
and you go
oh yep there's me talking [ __ ] to myself
again
all right now what i got to do is for
every one negative thought
i've got to replace the three positive
thoughts so i've got to say okay
all right you know oh look at you know
whatever it is that you say about
yourself and you go to a mirror and you
say okay
i've got to look myself dead in the eye
and this is what gets hard for people
look
i'm gonna look myself dead in the eye
and it's gonna feel real weird you guys
say i gotta say
three things that i love about myself
and you gotta sit there and you've gotta
say this and
i was taught this when i was 19 years
old when i first got into personal
development and self-development
everything
and one of my mentors said go to the go
to the mirror every morning
look yourself in the eye and say i love
you a hundred times
and you say i love you i love you i love
and over and over and over and over
again
and i went from literally it was like a
reprogramming of my own mind i used to
talk a whole lot of [ __ ] i used to
be really down on myself i used to find
all the negative things i hate about
myself
and when i started with this practice it
was like i almost was just like pulling
all of these weeds out
unconsciously yeah and then i started
noticing all of the things i like about
myself like my girlfriend she's like
when we first started dating we've been
together for for seven years now she was
like
you're kind of uh you're kind of like
really into yourself and i'm like
i'm not into myself i just really want
to build myself up because i know how
important that is well it's not cocky
it's
you're being confident there's a
difference and um you're not being full
of yourself i think that there is
so much more benefits to having that
positive self-talk constantly and just
kind of hyping it being your own height
man but because it's so much easier
than the way you are with your friends
your
your career your even with yourself
everything changes when you have that
mindset of going i love myself i know i
can do it
so would you just say that's the way to
be confident is
really just telling yourself reminding
yourself it's a job it's basically
you're kind of having to retrain
reprogram your brain
and telling you i love myself without
feeling like you want to
cringe every time you say i mean i
remember someone told me
um every day go look in the mirror and
have an intention and just say something
whether it's like a body part or your
mind or this and
it felt really weird the first week
doing it and then it became just
something
habitual and i just didn't stop is that
a good just starting point for people
that lack
100 so there's there's there's two ways
to i always say there's two ways to get
confidence
right nobody's here's the first thing
that's important nobody's born with
confidence
right nobody's born with it so when you
see a confident person that's somebody
who
has built that confidence in themselves
and i'm not talking about cockiness i'm
talking about confident like they walk
in
you guys know a confident person when
they walk into the room there's like a
presence
that they have there's an energy like
you can literally feel them walking in
and so
there's two ways to get it number one is
results and number two
is showing up for yourself so so results
if
if i go oh i want my business to do a
hundred thousand dollars a month
this month and we've never done it and
we hit that number it's going to give me
some confidence
right yeah the other way behind the
scenes of doing it though
so 100 definitely talk positively
yourself but one thing that i think is
so underestimated with people is to show
up for yourself when no one else is
around so let me give you a good example
right
i know i'm supposed to make the bed and
if i don't make the [ __ ] bed
there's a it's like a little hit of i
didn't do that i should have done that
today
right if i walk if i take if i want to
change my shirt and i change my shirt
i can throw that shirt that i just got
done you know i pick my new shirt i
throw my other one that's on
i throw it on top of the bed i throw it
on top of a chair i know i'm supposed to
put that away
i know i need to and so it's these
little tiny things throughout the day
where i have to show up for myself
and then if i you know get done with
this this mug and i'm done with it i can
put inside of
the the sink or i can wash it off dry it
off and put it back inside so it's these
little teeny tiny things that go
right i'm showing up for myself in all
of the little things because the way you
do one thing is the way do everything so
if i'm showing up for myself all these
little things
i'm for sure going to show up to myself
with all these big things i would say
confidence is like building blocks you
just stack them on top of each other
and then one day you look back and
you're like oh i'm a different person
than i was
i think that is so important being there
for yourself and doing those little
things because i think
human nature it's very easy just to get
lazy and just get stuck in your ways and
you know i'm that kind of person where
if i have one shirt on my bed that i
just decided not to wear it'll
be five shirts and then ten shirts and
then i have a mountain of clothes that
i'm like oh my god i haven't put any of
this away yeah and then in
in turn that builds stress on me and
then i start getting anxiety because i
have a pile of clothes oh
all of these things that we're talking
about really go hand in hand with the
other like if you're not confident with
yourself
you won't be confident in pursuing a
career that you want then you won't be
then that career won't be the future
that you want
i listened to one of your recent um
episodes or i think i was on youtube and
you were literally talking about the
idea of this guy saying that you
couldn't run
a mile under three minutes and then i
loved that
analogy or that comparison then the fact
when the moment happened when the guy
could run
a mile under three minutes everyone
started being able to and it's that
limitation you put on yourself how do
you get rid of that limitation when
you don't probably have someone around
you just like proving that you could do
it that you have to prove it yourself
how can you be that first person that
runs three mile
so the whole thing with the um so what
you're talking about is a beautiful
story so there's a guy named roger
bannister so before
1952 nobody had ever run a mile in under
four minutes
it was like literally your heart was
going to explode is what they thought
like it was physically impossible for
someone to do it
and nobody had ever done in the history
of mankind and roger bannister did it
one time and he ran in three three
minutes 59 seconds
in like some change like literally just
under four minute mile
the next two years 200 people ran under
four minutes in a mile
simply because they went oh it's
possible so now when you think about
this
i don't like running at all so i'm not
running any four minute mile i'm
probably not even hitting an eight
minute mile
there's no way right like that's not my
jam the easy way to gain the confidence
into doing this so
let's take my example that i said a
hundred thousand dollars in a month
which is
a lot for some people right yeah let's
say that i'm just like
let's go simple everybody wants to have
a better body right everybody wants to
work out
i'm not going to celebrate getting done
and getting the body that i want
so there's a there's a thing called
dopamine that your your brain releases
and you can
set these dopamine reward systems i had
dr andrew huberman on my
podcast he's a neurobiologist out of
stanford and
what what most people do is we associate
i should only get to reward myself
whenever i get the body that i want
yeah but it's gonna take you three six
twelve months possibly to get the body
that you want
and what happens is when you finally get
that thing win the champion for what
whatever it is
dopamine releases in your brain dopamine
makes you feel good
dopamine is the chemical of motivation
it makes you want to do more
yeah so if that's the case why would i
take dopamine and release it at the very
end when i hit my goal
versus setting up what's called a
dopamine reward system so
literally instead of me getting the body
i want
walking into the gym will should i
should celebrate myself for walking into
the gym and
showing up for myself okay that makes
sense yeah and so what happens is your
brain starts to kind of get addicted to
these dopamine ward systems
the biggest dopamine reward system these
phones they're literally built to give
you dopamine that's what it is
you get little hits of dopamine so i'm
gonna go okay if i want to create the
body that i want instead of me being
like
this body sucks my ass looks like [ __ ] i
don't want to like and you just like
yell at yourself when you don't have
what you
you ins go well when i finally have the
body i want then i'm going to be
nice to myself no it's like i walked
into the gym today
i'm going to celebrate that and what
happens is that makes you want to do it
again because your brain went ah that
feels good your body went oh that feels
good
okay i'm not even going to worry about
doing 15 sets
i'm going to do 10 reps of on the squat
rack
and as soon as i get done with that i'm
going to tell myself
good job and once you do that you feel a
little bit better and a little bit
better so i want to keep doing this and
so
it's not about attaching all of your
happiness to the end goal
it's about attaching it to these little
teeny tiny things that you do throughout
the day
i would love to talk about um
manifestation because we know that
you're really into it and sophia and i
i mean i kind of got her into like the
whole law of attraction manifesting
because i believe in it we're at the
point where we'll manifest
um rain to go away like we will do
anything
the power manifestation our definition
that we've explained
to our listeners i feel like is not
correct
so if you could give a better version of
manifestation
so let's let's make it simple so
manifestation can
seem like super spiritual and for for
for me like i'm very analytical so i can
dance in like the analytical science
world or i can dance in the woo
you know so i've done both i can go
anywhere we want to go and so
knowing that your listeners are going to
be on both sides and i kind of try to
explain it to them so
the law of attraction is simply this i
think of something
and i get something now if you want to
figure out exactly how that works
so on a scientific side there's a part
of your brain called the reticular
activating system
this is when you buy a new car and you
see the car everywhere the car didn't
just
it didn't just magically appear
everywhere and everyone started buying
car the same car when
when you did right what happened is the
reticular activating system in your
brain started to notice this so
the reticular activating system at any
moment in time right now
our brains could take in about 2
trillion bits of information
but it filters out all of that except
for 200 bits of information per second
the only things that it allows into your
brain is something that makes sense to
it
so when you buy a car you now own that
car that's why you see the car
everywhere
the other day about six months ago um a
guy that i knew from
middle school passed away and i was
looking through his facebook so i was
like oh i wonder what i haven't seen him
in so long i wonder what happened
and i saw an old old friend from middle
school so we're talking
20 years ago now right i saw a picture
of him and i was like oh my gosh i
wonder what's going on with him i
haven't seen him in so long
next day i'm at the coffee shop and i'm
working i'm sitting there and i look up
and i see a guy walk into the coffee
shop with his dog
and i'm like oh my god that's ryan
that's his name i was like oh my god
that's ryan and then i saw him walk in
and then i saw him walk through and i
saw him in the window and i was like oh
that's not ryan
but then i went holy [ __ ] i'm only
thinking that's ryan because i saw a
picture of ryan yesterday right
right so what happens is is i wake up in
the morning and i know what i want
i know who i want to be i know the
future i want to create i know how i
want to show up
everything i know all of that stuff the
reason why that's important though
is because now i'm setting my brain to
look for those things throughout the day
right so it's it brings in the people
places opportunities and things that you
need to to create that future so if i
say
i want to you know uh manifest
a uh a girlfriend right if i was
thinking i was like i want to manifest
her girlfriend
right well then i need to be very clear
on what i want her to look like what i
want her to talk like how i want her to
be
where she hangs out because then i'm
going to start to notice
any girl that resembles the girl in my
head whenever i go out into public
and so rob you're telling me right now i
can manifest a boyfriend
exactly how i but here do you want to go
do you want to go deeper into it all
right
all right so ready here's how you when
you're talking about focus on this right
now like this is the only thing
so we're talking about manifesting
somebody okay um
here's what's what's what's really
interesting about it is that
you've walked up to somebody before and
you've felt something doesn't feel right
right like it's not what they say it's
not the way they look but there's just
your body and their body are just not
really there's something going on you
can feel something's wrong
and you've you've listened to it before
but she also not listened to it before
and then it kicks you in the ass later
on you're like
i knew it i shouldn't have gone on a
date with him or
shouldn't have trusted her or whatever
it was oh yeah
you've felt it before what happens is
our bodies are constantly vibrating at
every second so like
i look when you see me i look like a
person
but really i'm a collection of 70
trillion cells and those cells are all
vibrating
and so what happens is this is if you
walk up to somebody and it feels good
what that's actually called is constru
on a scientific scale it's called
constructive interference it means that
your wavelengths and my wavelengths are
actually lining up
which makes ours double which is why if
you're around someone you just met them
never met them before but you just get
this good feeling and you you can sit
and talk to them for like two hours
it's because their energy and your
energy are lining up
and it doubles it so when we have the
same wavelength our wavelengths will
double
which makes us both feel better now if i
come up to you and i have a different
vibration than you or some you know
there's an evil person whatever it is
they will actually it's called
destructive interference
your body will feel the destruction of
your waves and their waves together will
cancel each other out
and so when you want to manifest
somebody you're ready here's the
important part
you make a list of everything that you
want to know about like
what you how you want him to act how you
want him to talk to himself
how how you want him to hold himself
accountable you know does he work out
all of that stuff
you make this list of what you want of
that person
but you only attract what you are so you
have to become
what's on the piece of paper because
that's when you attract that person
because if you're not on the same level
as this person
then guess what's going to happen he's
going to notice the destructive
interference because you're not on the
same wavelength
mic drop might like that drop that one
you got to become
who you want to attract because that's
how you attract people well that makes
sense that makes sense because we we
were always into these like mood boards
and that's what we would do we put like
what we put up for our love life and
then career and we put photos of an
apartment and
you know it kind of worked in some way
honestly it did some ways like we had
honestly it was kind of weird a building
in florida we're in florida right now
we had a podcast studio that kind of
looked like this we're here
but i feel like when it comes to career
and um specifically like just
how to like i i manifest every day like
i'll think about
an office building and a big window and
i'll sit there and they say feel it like
you're actually there and then let it go
is that something that you do like if
people are wanting to manifest or have
law of attraction for their
careers do how do they even do that like
i mean it's easy to kind of do
a boyfriend or a girlfriend because you
can list the qualities you want and then
you
need to try to become that easy until
you try it sophia well i can do it
i know i can do it positive self-talk
but when it comes to
aspirations and things like that where
people are really like i want to make
money and i want you to give us a
house give us a manifesting starter kit
if i want a dream job what would i do
today perfect so all right so here's the
thing that i think is important what i
always tell people
is i'm really big into visualization and
i'm not really that good at it from
being honest
i'm not good at seeing it but i'm good
at feeling it like in having the feeling
of what it would be like
yeah so what you do is you fast forward
let's say you want to fast forward five
years right you want to get this perfect
career you want to have the life that
you want boyfriend girlfriend
family whatever it is you sit down and
you visualize it
and get as clear as you possibly can as
to what it is that it looks like
every single aspect of it that you can
and what you want to do is you want to
bring those feelings
in right because we're not thinking
about it we're trying to feel it because
the feeling is the vibration side of it
right so you figure out what you want in
five years the career the family the
house the cars the kids
the happiness the love the the house
that's on the beach all of that stuff
you write it all down on a piece of
paper because when something's in your
head it's super abstract like it's hard
to take something and conceptualize
something when it's in your head but
when you put it on paper
it just makes a whole lot more sense
right so you look at all of those things
the immediate thought that everyone has
is what do i need to do to get all of
that
which is important you do have to do
stuff to do things like the
when you go to the law of attraction i
always say the part that's left out of
the law of attraction
is the last six letters of attraction
which is action
you've got to actually get your ass up
and do something that's so true there's
so many times where i'm like thinking
about something i'm like wait i actually
need to go
do it because i can't just think i'm
going to give you a million dollars your
dream boyfriend's not going to come
knock on your door if you don't leave
the house like you've got to go out to
where they are
right it's so that's true it's so true
because
we'll be on our phone kicking ourselves
that we're not pursuing what we really
want but we'll still be on our phone
like why why why can't we just get up
and do it because we think that it's
just going to come
it's like it's this instant
gratification we're like oh we don't
really need to work on it you have to
work you have to put in the work
you got to put the action in so so what
you do is do you need to do things of
course
but what you do is you look at that
dream life and you say okay not it's not
what i need to do it's who i need to
become in order to have that life if you
look at anybody successful it's because
they've built themselves into the person
that can
attract that success you know jim rohn
who's
one of tony robbs's mentor says that
success is something that you attract by
the person that you become
right it's not anything that you do so
when you look at it you say okay
i don't have the life that i want or the
business or the success that i want
because i'm not the person who deserves
it yet i'm not the person that can
create that yet what you do is you make
a list of this
dream life everything that you want you
see it feel it all that stuff
and then you say okay if i were to just
take myself out and say i'm not even
myself i'm just looking at this person
who has this dream life that i want
let me describe this person in as much
detail as i possibly can
what time do they wake up do they make
their bed you know what side of the bed
they wake up on what are they eating for
breakfast when are they working out
who are they hanging out with are they
spending time on their phone how often
are they working how often are they
spending around people that are
motivating them what are they doing and
you build this person out as if it's
somebody else
and then you just wake up you visualize
that thing every single morning
and then you think about the you've got
the list of who you need to be
and you just simply act as if you just
become that person
and eventually what happens is because
you put the work in
the success will kind of tail behind you
and eventually in the future they'll
catch up and you'll go oh i have the
future i wanted
because i became the type of person that
could create that future
i'm going to wake up and i'm going to
set my gps for who i need to be
how i need to be and i'm going to be
that person every single day
just set your gps in the morning we are
bouncing around we are like nomads in
the morning
i know this is what we need to start
doing i would love to know what your
morning routine looks like
because i feel like you have probably
just a really killer one
yeah so it's it's pretty good i always
say
here's the thing that i say before
because mine's pretty intense right i
know
i wanna hear it i wake up in the morning
brush my teeth do all the stuff you need
to
get water i don't have coffee for at
least an hour to an hour and a half
first thing i do in the morning is i
meditate because your brain waves are
actually at usually theta state theta
state is where you're
most uh close to hypnosis every child
from zero to seven years old they're
usually
reason why they learn so quickly and
their brain changes so much is because
they're usually in theta state
right when you start waking up and you
go further into it you start doing
things you go into alpha beta gamma so
you go further into it
but the thing about it for me is i wake
up and i meditate
and for me i have a uh
i have everything that i want to be what
do i need to do to be more loving what i
need to do to be more kind
and i focus on all of that and try to
bring it into me
so that's the first part of the morning
routine then usually i get up and uh i
have a cold plunge
it's on the other side of this wall you
can't i don't think you guys can hear it
running but it's
it's running so it's like you do like a
polar plunge basically everything 40
degrees
yeah so 40 degrees is what does that do
does that just wake you
get you from like theta waves to some
other wave well so there's a lot of
so there's a lot of body benefits my
benefit is that in order to be
successful
you've got to do things you don't want
to do and there's no part of me that
wants to jump into 40 degrees
any morning ever never i actually should
make a
minute yeah i make as many as many
excuses as i possibly can and it's i
always call it like the inner [ __ ] like
i've got the inner [ __ ] inside of me
like and that voice that's like don't do
it rob nobody's nobody's gonna know if i
don't do it
nobody but i'll know it's true right
yeah you're like if i can freeze myself
i can basically go to work and do
everything you need to do all day
you meditate you take your polar plunge
what's next work out so i work out next
so i have a sauna as well so i jump in
the sauna to get my muscles warm again
because i was just cold
um and then i do a workout and so my
workouts immediately right after that
and then usually what i'll do is i'll go
and i'll get food and then i have my
entire team call so i have a team call
for an hour after that
and uh so it literally goes wake up
meditate
uh do breath work the breath work is is
called wim hof so i do wim hof it's just
i was just gonna ask if it was that one
where you do the like quick inhale
yeah yep i almost passed three rounds
three rounds of 30 breaths jump inside
of the cold plunge
then go inside of the sauna to warm
myself back up and get my muscles warm
and then i do a workout and then i
usually eat after that and that's when i
allow myself to have coffee
because there's a whole lot of studies
of of you need to wait an hour until
after you work out there's reason
hour after you wake up in order to have
coffee um there's reasons for that but
for me it's just like
you know it's it's just mental training
everything in life is
is mental training everything
yeah so there's there's reasons for it
is because your body's still making
melatonin which is what makes you tired
um when you wake up in the morning
another thing you could do is if the
to release and get your body to stop
making your brain stop making melatonin
is if the sun's already out is look at
the blue in the sky because there's
there's
receptors in your eyes that when it sees
the blue tells your brain to stop making
melatonin because it's
daytime so the reason why everybody has
the night shift on their phone to get
rid of the blue
is because the blue is what tells your
body to stop making melatonin but at
night
you want your body to make melatonin so
that you fall asleep easier
that makes sense that's really cool
that's really cool this is like a little
life hack
yeah that's so great let's i live my
life off of life hacks if i can
understand how my brain and body work
my whole life is so much easier thank
you so much for coming on the show today
plug all of your socials and where
everyone can find your podcast and just
find out more about you
yeah so the podcast is called the
mindset mentor it comes out monday
tuesday wednesday thursday and friday so
five times a week
most of them are usually about 15 20
minutes long and then i have some
interviews that are longer and
and stuff um and then my uh social is
everything is rob dial junior
r-o-b-d-i-a-l-j-r
um i post [ __ ] three times a day on
instagram and about 12 times a day on
facebook so
yeah it's it's uh i've got almost 300
000 followers on instagram but i've got
2.7 million i think on facebook so i did
a lot of viral videos on there for
motivation stuff we gotta do more no
excuses no we don't have two accounts
what's wrong with you gosh okay we're
getting better from this day from this
conversation we're becoming better
people
so yeah thank you so much thank you so
much i'll check on you i'm not i'm not
screwing around i'm gonna check on you i
know i feel like i'm like
i honestly don't doubt that for a second
i'm a little bit nervous but i need it
i'm ready thank you so much from all of
us here at the show
thanks for staying on wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at
unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week